to learn more about how to critically
engage and understand western political
philosophy and its attendant political
and ethical systems courses are
available by the quran institute which
can be accessed via the link i would say
that islam actually manages plurality
better than liberalism but those who
don't believe in the islamic purpose of
life islamic law while it might underpin
the security of the lands and the state
and hence will prevent robbers and
invading armies and things like that um
it's not there to make jews christians
and zosterians and others and better
muslims because they're not muslims so
in islam christians and jews could
actually have their own law courts their
own law courts their own in some cases
even their own um
police and semi-autonomous areas no one
was telling them that they're against
the they are not following the values of
the state or they're not integrating um
or assimilating into the into the wider
society there was no such challenges in
liberal societies however
the idea of a one law for all sounds
very laudable at first but when you
actually think about how you apply this
you're basically saying that one law
might be determined by the majority
let's say or at least representatives of
the majority
will basically
impose one particular law system on
everyone including the minorities that
might disagree with those with the law
system and basically that that can
involve a form of intolerance where
communities are told that you can't do
these certain practices with because it
it doesn't conform with the law of this
country or you're not allowed to have
your own law system because that is
interrogation of the of this one law for
all what you find is that muslims and
historically jews but as sometimes also
catholics their their own law systems
were viewed as active threats to the
state right now it's muslims muslims a
practice of just even voluntary uh
islamic law courts or more like
tribunals they're not really islamic
they're not courts really but they're
just tribunals um
are viewed as a threat to the state and
the state now state must clamp down upon
these or regulate it or or get involved
in their religious life and affairs
because it is viewed as a as a threat so
those are the issues that liberalism has
a problem with tolerance of multiple
ways of life other than its own
i'd say in practice whereas islam
actually allows
separate law systems
for jews and christians and others to
practice their own laws amongst
themselves islam kind of offers more
tolerance
than liberalism only because islam
doesn't view itself it can't view itself
as imposing itself on everybody because
the purpose in life is to voluntarily
choose the to worship the creator to
recognize his existence and to um follow
his commands and must be done
voluntarily it can't be done by
imposition whereas liberalism believes
that liberalism itself is universal
justice for mankind and so if it's
universal justice for mankind then every
human on this earth has a right
to liberalism whether they like it or
not
and so it means that there can only be
one law for all in every liberal state
but it can also mean that liberal states
can exercise uh colonialism as it's
called to export its its ideology to the
world because it believes that every
human being has a right to what it calls
with its own definition of human rights
irrespective of whether those people
like it or not or agree with it or
accept it and so on so forth colonialism
was justified from a liberal
rubric i mean i think that there are
a few things to
keep separate in the discussion
one thing is about the distinction about
the laws that you apply within a state
and what you think governs the behaviour
of states and liberalism was a doctrine
about
what happens within a state it wasn't a
doctrine that spoke to relationships
between states
and there's a kind and there are kind of
very obvious differences here because
within a state you've got a government
all the citizens are subject to the
government the nations are not subject
to any kind of ruler and so you
shouldn't be
thinking as you very quickly said that
um
liberal theory was used to justify
colonialism that's actually i think not
true you said that liberal theory was
never used to justify colonialism uh
because states in their international
relations uh were not subject or
beholden to laws whereas domestically
they're beholden to their own laws
um
i think i would disagree
john stuart mill if you with many he
wrote made many tracks about um how
colonism can be justified and why and
why it's a good thing and what should be
the policy of liberal states um
concerning foreign relations with quote
unquote barbaric nations eventually they
will have to be subdued and they will
have to be control of an iron fist until
they are able if they adopt liberalism
then they then they can be independent
and autonomous and they've reached much
maturity now the thing is this that when
any state goes to war the state has to
explain to its people why it's going to
war it can't just say hey we're going
for money we're going for wealth or fame
the people just wouldn't accept
especially in them in uh representative
systems whereby you know political
parties want to get reelected
so they make excuses like um or that
they have to give some justification
that the people will accept at the very
least uh whether it be civilizing the
natives
we're doing it for their own good we're
educating them for their own good we
have to go over there and give them
superior enlightened values so liberal
theory has been used to justify
colonialism very much so um
tocqueville
mentions that discusses this
as well as many others so i would i
would very much disagree um that label
theory has not been used to justify
colonism indeed it was centrally located
in justifying colonialism because the
people wouldn't accept any other ex any
other reason why you're going around the
world and sending british troops to die
for what purpose
graham what do you make of that i
one thing is to distinguish between
liberal theory what the theory says and
what liberal theorists have said when
they're speaking about other matters and
when it comes to the question i mean
when when i said look liberal theory is
a theory about the state it's not a
theory about international affairs and
you started talking about what some
liberal theorists said about
international affairs that doesn't mean
that what they were giving you were some
consequences of liberal theory they were
just giving their independent views
about how they thought international
affairs should go and it's that's just
got no consequences for liberal theory
as a theory of the running of the state
there's an another thing is that
um
liberalism like islam has a very long
history and
i
you have to draw a distinction one
distinction is between
theory and practice what the theory
tells you another thing is and this is
another point about history that
certainly with liberalism there's a
development over time and
the theory improves and there are ideas
that were had by
the founding fathers people like hume
and locke and can't that have been
disavowed by subsequent generations of
liberals and you can't prove anything by
appealing to things that they said
the professor says quite
quite um
uh yeah happily that
there's liberal theory in his liberal
theorists and so just because one of the
founding fathers of america might have
slaves it doesn't mean that liberalism
believes in slavery which i i totally um
would concur with him on that but then
this brings us to the fundamental
problem of actual liberalism itself
um what is the holy book of liberalism
uh the text that we can refer to that
limits of the amount of interpretation
that can come from uh from liberalism
sets uh parameters to it well there
isn't any
so then what then makes something
liberal what what so what is liberal
theory it's not a platonic form that
floats around
uh that we can access and refer to but
liberal theory is
uh is anything that liberals say it is
is my point and when i was talking about
john when i was talking about um sorry
people liberal theorists advocating
colonialism or what have you um it
wasn't perhaps them just saying i think
colonialism colonialism is a good idea
they wrote detailed tracts
relating their own thinking the thinking
they're on the books and in fact on
liberty the classical book by john
street mill talks about
uh imperialism and colonialism and
justifies it in his own book on liberty
which is viewed as a a great reference
for for classical liberals but for
social liberals mostly
right as in we're under social
liberalism today um as the most dominant
form of liberalism today we know this as
liberal interventionism of a different
kind so i'll be spreading democracy um
is also a key argument or spreading
freedom uh was also used to justify the
war in afghanistan you could also want
to read all the books by john street
mill like on the treatment of barbarous
nations um
he discussed that in a bit more depth
but you can see his justification for
colonialism and imperialism in his book
on liberty which is a very seminal book
of political philosophy by john street
mill you if if ever you're going to
study the the political philosophy of
john's journal upon which much of the
current day modern liberalism or
self-social liberalism uh or at least
from the anglo-saxon perspective is
certainly um
based upon on liberty is the most
preeminent book of his there there is no
separation between liberal theory and
liberal theorists if the liberal
theorist is using is making a
philosophical a politically flawful
argument about something related to
their their other ideas then it's part
of liberal um theory i would say there
is nothing there's no holy book uh of
liberalism which is
why you would probably get more
diversity and interpretation and hence
more lack of clarity in political
philosophy and then one where you have a
holy book which
at least limits the amount of possible
interpretations that one um can can
produce as to the practice of the
prophet muhammad sallallahu alaihi
sallam's sayings to the actions of
muslims um we can make a a quite a
definitive border between those two
think we can certain circumscribe uh
that the prophet muhammad salallahu is
as we believe is a prophet and his
sayings are the basis of our ethics of
our law uh but muslim activities or
actions are not
and can never be and so if the prophet
muhammad salallahu said it if the quran
says something
it has absolute authority um from our
perspective and
overrides anything else
that we might um want to bring
later on and i think that is a good
thing having laws and ideas founded upon
immovable and immutable bases prevents
people from abrogating these ideas later
in in a civilization
i i guess abdullah is making the claim
that there's a centrality that the
islamic tradition has that we can sort
of put a discrete boundary out around
right say this is within the tradition
this is not uh this is history history
is not legal precedence this is legal
prisoners legal precedence is in let's
say the form of their heads or the
whatever jurisprudence um that we have
and that
perhaps liberalism and this is one of
the questions that was asked um
is is it true then that liberalism fails
to have this first principles approach
of creating a boundary by which it
defines what is and isn't liberalism and
in failing to do so
carves opened the space for
i guess projects like the colonial
project which was to enlighten the rest
of the world with a very eurocentric
vision of what it means to be the good
okay so there's a few things i wanted to
respond to and
to learn more about how to critically
engage and understand western political
philosophy and its attendant political
and ethical systems courses are
available by the quran institute which
can be accessed via the link